- Hi everyone.
First of all, I just wanna
say thank you for joining
and taking the time to attend our session.
And I want to, today
we're here to talk about,
talk about cloud mesh and
potential different solutions.
I'm Frank, and this is Jakub.
- Hi, Frank, hi everybody,
my name is Jakub,
and I first wanted to ask who
has heard of HAProxy before?
It's a lot of people.
And who uses HAProxy right now?
Awesome.
So some of you, see my
colleague in the back,
we have a T-shirt for you.
Thank you for using HAProxy.
If he runs out, then
please see us at the booth
and we'll get you on.
- All right, so for today,
we wanted to talk about
"Multi-Cloud Chaos,
The Unified Cloud Mesh Architecture."
We want to tell you
some tales of the field.
We work on the enterprise side
and we talked to a lot
of different enterprises
and they're looking at
service mesh solutions.
So I'll start with a statement,
"The Service Mesh was designed
to solve connectivity."
However, for most organizations,
it simply shifted complexity elsewhere.
Let's dive into something,
some of the issues that we've observed.
If you look at today's
modern infrastructure,
it's fractured.
It wasn't built, it evolved.
There's multiple clouds, multiple regions,
on-prem data centers, legacy
applications that can't change,
and most service meshes weren't
built with this in mind.
They struggled to integrate
the brownfield enterprise.
Then, you have the mesh tax.
The two most prominent
architectures and service meshes,
you have the sidecar architecture
and the sidecar-less architecture.
When you look at the sidecar architecture,
it's basically one sidecar per pod
or per instance of your service.
And this simply becomes too expensive
and complex as we scale.
Then, you have the
sidecar-less architecture,
which is better, however
complexity is shifted elsewhere
to different components.
You have the Layer 4
proxy, usually per node,
and then you have Layer 7 proxy,
which is a Layer 7 proxy,
so it's split into distributed components,
usually per namespace or service account
if you're using Kubernetes
and these types of things.
So it's less overall,
but there's still operational complexity
in dealing with that.
And crucially, both
architectures still fail at
preventing resource sprawl as you scale,
managing North-South traffic,
they primarily focus on East-West only,
and federation or
multi-cloud region setups
have difficulty or emerging right now.
They require additional components
or were not considered with
the initial architecture.
So the problem isn't the
service, it's the boundary.
We've been hyper-focused on services,
but the real challenge
is the network boundary.
What if we stop trying to
manage sprawling sidecar
and proxy deployments
and instead deploy strategic
gateways at network boundaries?
This on the HAProxy side
is what we call the universal mesh.
So if you take a look at
it, this is a mock-up,
but it's basically you can have
an outer edge and an inner edge
because HAProxy is omnidirectional.
So it could do North-South or East-West.
And you could take, on the outer edge,
some of the most popular
things are TLS termination,
security, centralized
logging, rate limiting,
and on the inner edge,
it's mostly East-West traffic.
So think about rate limiting,
think about traffic splitting,
other complexities that you see
in today's modern infrastructure.
So if to sum it up,
essentially our universal
mesh is simpler, flexible,
and a more powerful
architecture backed by HAProxy
with 20 years of proven
reverse proxy excellence.
We focus on convergence, federation,
and that gives you the universal mesh.
So on the convergence side,
it's the ingress, the mesh,
and proxies all become one.
It's one HAProxy managing that.
Federation, it's out of the box.
We've built this, we've built
federation with this in mind,
so it's most effortless multi-cluster
or multi-cloud or multi-region
And that gives you unified security,
connectivity and observability,
which is the primary purpose of the mesh.
- Frank, I would just add that I think
that the multi-cloud kind of connectivity
and multi-cluster
connectivity problem is real.
I don't know if you've noticed,
but AWS announced I think
today morning that they're,
they have a new solution
called multi-connect
or something like that,
where they're actually partnering with GCP
to do connectivity between AWS
GCP and then other networks.
So something that you
were able to do before,
but now there's a single API call
to connect all of these clouds.
And they operate on a Layer
3, so different than us,
but this kind of shows you
how much demand there is
for basically multi-cloud, multi-connect,
multi-cluster connectivity
because everybody's trying
to solve this problem.
- So we think the universe mesh
solves impossible problems.
It connects everything.
It's a single pattern that simplifies
operational complexity
and resource utilization.
It's multi-cluster and federation-ready,
so it understands resources
and understands infrastructure,
spans cluster without forcing
architectural compromises.
It's the same pattern everywhere.
And there's flexible deployment.
You can run gateways
external to Kubernetes,
inside Kubernetes, inside
EC2 instances, EKS, ECS.
It's really flexible.
So if you want to take a look at this,
this is kind of a typical mock-up
of an architectural diagram.
You'd have the control
plane, which is fusion.
All service meshes kind of have,
they're broken up with a
control plane and a data plane,
and then you'd have the data
plane layer, which is HAProxy,
which empowers all of the features
that you can see on the side,
and that this is proxying
to any number of services.
If we're talking about AWS, you have,
you can use ECS or
Elastic Container Service,
EC2, auto-scaling groups
as well, Kubernetes,
basically anything we can route to
or we can route to anything.
And then we can also do the
same for any virtual machine
or any on-premise or any other region.
It's basically all controlling
or all controlled
through the control plane
in a single management plane.
So that gives you kind
of the building blocks
of a modern mesh.
On the inside, you want to talk
the most important features are,
you're looking for performance,
you're looking for zero trust,
you're looking for multi-layered security,
authentication and authorization,
and federation again as well.
So let's dive into our sweet spot.
We are the world's fastest
application delivery
and security platform,
and we do have the proof to back it up.
In 2021, we released our article
showing that you can achieve
2 million requests per second
on a single AWS instance.
It was a Graviton2 at the time.
And basically, this has been never seen.
So it's really sheer performance
and it's one of the
core tenets of HAProxy.
In everything that we deliver,
its performance,
reliability, and scalability,
all of that is in mind.
What happened though
is after that release,
in 2023, we realized there was
a dramatic performance loss
in the new LTS version of the current
TLS library we were using,
and efforts with the authors
failed to yield acceptable results.
So what did we do?
In 2024, we reworked our entire TLS stack
to support modern TLS libraries.
And in 2025, released a
performance build using AWS-LC.
That was the one we, that
was the library we selected
as a default TLS library,
and we also have modern
alternative support.
So compatibility supports
for anything that's delivered
by the OS as well, if
you want to use that.
And it's always our commitment
is to do whatever it takes
to deliver the best performance.
And then, we didn't really
release a benchmark,
but we just released HAProxy 3.3,
and we're sharing some of
our internal benchmarks.
So what we've done is we did
the exact same test that we did in 2021.
And obviously, the natural
sentiment we think,
"Oh, since 2021, the hardware has become
so much more powerful.
You should see an increase."
But the reality in today's
world, since 2021 to 2025,
we've actually released
10 separate versions.
And what you're seeing in modern software
is the phenomenon of software bloat.
Every release has more features,
more resource, it takes more resources,
so it basically takes
away from the advantages
that you're gaining from the hardware.
So what we saw when we benched
it on the exact same test,
right now it's pretty much
the exact same instance
except it's the Graviton4,
the most recent graviton
that's been released,
we were able to achieve 2.54
million requests per second.
And to make sure that we're
testing on the same platform,
we re-ran the exact same
version on the exact instance.
So it's not anything related to hardware.
So we took the same instance, we ran 3.3,
then we ran 2.3, which is
the one we ran at the time,
and we yielded better results.
But however, the reality is that
even in 2021, we reached
hardware limitations.
So when you're doing such benchmarks,
you're really limited by the communication
in the internal CPU cache, right?
So if you're doing millions of operations,
the CPU cache and the
communication between it,
there's some resource problems
that are just not there yet on the chips.
And then you're also limited
by the network packets per second.
So even on the most modern CPUs,
there's only 16 network queues available.
And that does seem like a lot,
but when you're talking 4 to
5 million packets per second,
there's a lot of chances that
stuff gets into user land,
so it's consuming resources.
So what we've decided,
because we're reaching the hardware,
we decided that instead of
trying to go for a bigger number,
'cause in reality nobody
really needs this much traffic,
or if you do, it's great to have something
that does it on a single instance,
but we fixed other pieces
of our architecture
such as we optimize more
load-balancing algorithm.
So our least con algorithm,
our default algorithms,
we switched it from round robin to random
and we focused on a lot
of tuning in our queues
and in our counters
to enable to help with other bottlenecks.
'cause once you're at
the reverse proxy level,
you're load balancing traffic
in front of application servers.
And most people provision
their application servers
not to full utilization.
So if you can use the load balancer
to get more efficiency
on your entire form of
application servers,
then you're really gaining overall.
So our queuing system,
it really allows you to utilize
100% performance of your
application servers.
So we're not only empowering performance
on the load balancer level,
we're empowering your performance
on your entire application level as well.
And then if I'm on the
other side of the fence
and I'm actually running something
that needs 2 million
requests per second or more,
I wanna know how much that costs, right?
That's really the most important.
If you go to your CTO, he's gonna ask you,
"How much will it cost me to actually run
this entire workload?"
And if you look at the quick
back of the napkin nap,
back of the napkin math,
you can realize that a billion request,
a billion request actually costs 41 cents
on this instance type.
And we've benched it
that we can get it down
to something on the 20-cent range
if you go for, if you don't need
these amount of cores, 64 cores.
All this to say that when
it comes to performance,
there's nothing that can match HAProxy.
- I would say, Frank,
notice the c8gn instances.
My team actually benchmarks all instances
on AWS with HAProxy,
and we are a very
network-heavy application.
And so, if you go with like c8g instances,
you will very quickly run
out of network limits.
So notice that a lot of the
benchmarks use cgn instances
with the network-optimized cards
because otherwise you're
gonna run out of PPS limits
and bandwidth limit exceeded
and everything else on the instances.
So in these cases,
it's very important to
use the gn instances.
And as you can see,
we're very big fans of
the Graviton ones as well.
So they're the sweet spot for HAProxy.
- Then it comes to federation.
So two HAProxy, NIP as an
IP as long as it's routable.
So that empowers us to
use the control plane
to configure each of our
proxies independently.
So if you take a look at this picture,
the control plane can send
a different configuration
to US-east and to US-west to
each one of those instances,
however since the
control plane knows about
US-east and US-west,
it can also send that
information to all the proxies.
So if there's ever a situation,
and we have a lot of use cases
like on the payment provider side
where people are looking for
the redundancy or backup,
so when a transaction costs money
and if there is a failure,
there are no servers available
in a single instance,
they do want to crossover
even though it may cost a monetary value.
All of these things,
having the control plane outside
talking to the infrastructure
and being aware of the infrastructure,
really enables flexibility
and allows us to be truly any platform,
any service, any infrastructure.
And a lot of the use cases that we see
take full advantage of this.
If you take a look at,
we have a lot of, we have
an ad tech recommendation
for HAProxy in partnership with AWS.
We've worked with a lot of
the 5G or mobile providers
to really expand their coverage
in wavelength zones for AWS
where we install our own software
and then we discover resources
for the 5G Kubernetes cluster,
and basically we offer
native load balancing
for a 5G network in a remote region
where there's only wavelength zones.
And then as I mentioned
on payment provider side,
a lot of payment providers nowadays,
popular ones that are, you could
take a look at our website,
basically they have redundancy across
three or four different regions or zones
and they want to switch over.
They want region affinity,
so they want to stay on the
first one as much as possible.
But in the event of a service failure,
they allow them to cross over
and they want us to prioritize
which ones to cross over to,
and that's all configurable
out of the control plane
and out of the configuration.
Then, a key point of a
service mesh is zero trust.
So in terms of TLS, in
terms of certificates,
this is all handled between HAProxy
and the control plane itself,
either renewing the certificates,
accepting and verifying the certificates,
even on health checks
to the back-end servers,
client certificates, CA certificates,
all that stuff is handled
out of the box with HAProxy.
And then, we slide back
to the slide before,
you look at the performance.
We optimize performance at
level and we monitor it,
as I mentioned before,
we even move to AWS-LC,
which is kind of giving us more options on
the new types of quantum
encryption and stuff like that.
Haven't seen many use cases yet,
but we're trying to move
to a modern TLS library
that can enable these
workloads in the future.
And we're always on the
precipice of new technology,
we are looking...
We just released our experimental
version of kernel TLS
and Encrypted Client Hello,
so we're really being on the forefront
of all these platforms
and our all these RFCs.
Then another piece
that's really interesting
when it comes to a service mesh is really
authentication or authorization.
Basically, this diagram kind of shows you
how authentication and SSO modules work.
We do have modules on the enterprise side.
We can handle anything from openid, saml,
we even have adfs proxy protocol as,
there's a specific
Microsoft standard for adfs.
We have a module for that.
But in theory, basically, client
presents itself to HAProxy,
HAProxy can redirect or talk
to the IDP in the background,
and then pass on that information
to the back-end server.
So it's kind of seamless.
Then, you just have, maybe you have APIs
or you're using JWTs.
We have native support for JSON and JWTs.
So basically, these
functions can help you find
the algorithm, the issuer,
the expiry, the scope,
all that information
can all be natively done
inside of HAProxy and
has been for a while.
And then you can, based on what you find,
you can actually deny, approve,
and you can build your own
access control list on that side.
- [Jakub] As a side note,
HAProxy 3.3 that was released
yesterday, not yesterday, last week.
- Last week, yeah.
- [Jakub] ... last week
added support for JWE tokens.
So those are the encrypted JWT tokens.
So you can actually now
not just verify JWT tokens,
but you can decrypt them
first and then verify them.
So that was added to 3.3.
- Exactly.
And then common, sometimes
you want to have a language
based on the results
that you're gonna get,
and we see a lot of it in the field,
we see a lot of OPA,
so open policy agents.
So we do have support for that as well.
So if you need more complex policies,
you can define a policy in Rego
and basically we parse the input
and we decide to allow
it or not based on that.
So it's really super flexible
in terms of authentication
and authorization.
And then, I'm gonna hand it over to Jakub
to go over our multi-layered
security capabilities.
- Thank you.
So I'm gonna talk about
multi-layered security,
and really first introduce
what it means to me
to talk about multi-layered security.
And then, I'll talk about
how we're achieving that
in HAProxy in context
of performance, right?
Because you've noticed that we
talk about performance a lot
because in many cases,
security means performance implications,
and we don't think that
should be true, right?
So to me, multi-layered
security means a lot
combined with authentication,
authorization,
everything that Frank talked about,
but also detecting
application-layer DDoS attacks,
web scraping, brute forcing, comment spam,
vulnerability scanning, some
specific targeted exploitation.
And I'm gonna talk about the details here.
The web scraping, to me, is
one of the most important ones
because obviously with AI,
since we're all using AI, right,
there are a lot of websites
out there announcing
they're struggling with AI bots
scraping all of their sites
and there are many protections,
and you can definitely use
protections from HAProxy,
but there are many others to stop AI bots
from scraping your site
while you're fighting some
targeted attacks from AI scrapers
that are just trying to get
everything from your website.
So I usually define this as
multiple layers of
detection and decisioning.
And the reality is that
I'm gonna talk about
these layers as four separate layers,
but they all actually
work at the same time.
So the fact that I have
chosen to place these layers
in this order is just my choice, right?
In the end, they all,
all of what I'm gonna talk
about happens at the same time.
So I should be able to choose
which layer reacts first,
or just do all of the detection first
and then make a decision later
with some exceptions, right?
Because, for example here,
we're applying access control.
So if I'm applying the access control,
and for example, I'm denylisting
a specific IP address,
well if I've denylisted an IP address,
it doesn't make sense to try
to detect if it's a bot or not.
It doesn't matter to me.
I'm gonna deny it anyway, right?
So I can just deny right away.
So access control, like
deny specific IP addresses,
allow internal IP addresses,
allow specific monitoring systems
or deny specific fingerprints
or IP addresses coming from bots, right?
This is where we're kind of
starting that idea of the bots.
The idea that we use in HAProxy,
and this is thanks to
the HAProxy community
support for large files,
is that you can actually put millions
of IP addresses inside HAProxy
and say "Deny based on this list."
And looking up that IP
address in that list,
whether you're looking up the first one
or the number 1 million will
take a constant amount of time,
so you don't have to
worry about how to scale
for a large amount of IP address blocks.
This is all thanks to Will Tarreau,
who's the founder of HAProxy,
created this unique data structure
called Elastic Binary Tree.
I recommended write-up.
If you ever Google Elastic Binary Tree,
he has a big write-up on how it works
and how it scales to millions of items.
Then, I start rate calculation.
So I'm not denying, but I'm
calculating specific rates.
And even here I'm saying,
"Is it over a rate limit?"
But I don't care if it's
over a rate limit yet,
I'm just calculating a rate, right?
So I'm figuring out
based on an IP address,
bandwidth, label of a bot, URL
what's the rate of the request
from this specific client?
So rate limit is all
about grouping clients
or identifying individual
clients and saying,
"What's the rate of their request
so I can make decisions later?"
The problem is that in our experience,
static limits are hard, and
we think there's a better way.
I don't know if you've ever
ran rate limit in practice
in your own HAProxy or
any other reverse proxy,
but every time...
I think, Frank, in production,
you ran this, right?
Every time you set up rate limits,
you get it wrong every single time,
and now you don't know what the
rate limit should be, right?
Should it be 100 requests a second,
1,000 requests a second?
What if my traffic is normally
100 requests a second,
but I spike 2,000 requests
a second every day
during a specific hour?
Then I have to set the rate limit up
to that specific very high rate, right?
But then I can be attacked
during the low traffic periods.
So we built something we call
a global profiling engine
that allows me to aggregate statistics
and aggregate rates across
multiple instances of HAProxy
and then calculate
statistical aggregation.
So I can do things like,
"Hey, I'm gonna rate limit bots
over 1.5 to 95th percentile
of the rate same hour yesterday."
So I take a look at what's
the rate of the requests
during the same hour yesterday,
and then I take a 95th percentile on that,
and that's a specific number.
And I don't wanna probably block
or deny on that specific number
because that's a 95 percentile, right?
But let's decide on a ratio, 1.52,
depending on who it is.
And I start blocking on that
or rate limited on that,
and that gives me dynamic rate limit.
So I no longer have to
set static rate limits.
I do it dynamically.
And basically, the rate
limit actually changes
every hour or every second
or every five seconds
depending on how I set it up.
Next is bot detection.
There are a lot of bots out there.
There are bot-scraping
companies at the expo
right next to us selling
bot solutions, right?
And so, the reality is
that a lot of people
want to detect if the request
came from a bot or not.
And I'm not saying that if
the request came from a bot,
that's a bad thing.
It might not be a bad thing
for your specific situation, right?
But maybe you need to know
and you need to be able to identify those
and identify crawlers,
and that's the AI thing right now, right?
Can you identify crawlers
that are based on AI
that are good companies
out there that will say,
"Hey, I'm OpenAI," right,
and there are bad companies
out there that will hide
they're an AI scraper and
try to hide that from you
so they present themselves
as a standard browser
while it's one of the top four
or top five AI companies out there.
I'm not gonna name there.
And then, so think about this,
I did access control, I determined rates,
I determined if it's a bot or not,
now I need to do some security
in terms of attacks, right?
So I should run a web
application firewall.
And the problem with web
application firewalls usually
is latency and throughput.
So if you just enable standard
web application firewall
like one of the open source versions,
you will find out that
your latency goes up
and your throughput on your
reverse proxies goes down
because it just takes a lot to
actually detect the traffic.
So we actually built a WAF
with a latency that is not detectable.
So we had our own conference
and we had a customer of
ours came in and said,
"We enabled the WAF,
and then we got confused
because it felt like nothing happened,"
because they couldn't detect
a statistical difference
in first time to bite
when they enabled the WAF.
And then, I did a lot of detection.
And the reality is, as I mentioned,
you should decide early
in specific situations.
If an IP address is on a denylist,
we'll deny it right away.
We don't need to go all through
the hassle of bot detection,
WAF filter and everything else.
Deny it right away, right,
so you can do some early decisioning.
But very often we see the
customers do decisioning later
once they do all of the detection,
and they decide on a response.
So I can deny the request,
I can allow it, I can tarpit it.
It's a very popular thing where,
for example, on our network,
I don't know if you wanna mention that,
we tarpit customers or bots or bad clients
instead of denying them.
Because if we deny them,
they will detect we've denied them
and they will adjust, right,
so we tarpit them instead.
- Yeah, blocking is not
something we often see
or people usually have options to to do.
So it takes a lot of
decisions on the product side
or as an organization has to go through
change requests and stuff like that.
So it's not something we see commonly.
So we do offer you the ability
to make any decision, right,
or label it, observe it,
and make the decision later.
So this is, it's completely configurable
and that's some of the power
that we're offering as well.
- Yeah, most of our customers tarpit
or send traffic to limited back-end.
So like if you have a back-end
with your real servers
that can handle 10,000 requests a second,
they'll send the bad
behavior to a back-end
that can handle 100 requests a second.
So the users will not get blocked,
the bad users will not get blocked,
but at some point they're
gonna run out of resources
and think, "Oh I succeeded,
I brought your website down,"
and they might stop, right?
But in the end, your
normal users are still
going through the fast back-end
because you just limited the bad behavior.
So you don't show the
users, the bad users,
what happened and what you're doing
because, again, once
you start blocking them,
our experience is that
they start adjusting.
And so, you will be
playing a cat and mouse.
The other thing that very often we see is
show a captcha or some
kind of a challenge.
This is one of the popular
solutions recently.
I don't know if you've heard
of like JavaScript challenges,
Anubis, and a few others, which is really,
"I'm gonna allow the request
but I'm gonna ask you
to calculate two prime numbers first
and I want you to take 500
milliseconds doing that," right,
to slow them down with the idea of,
"I'm not gonna block them
but I wanna make it a
little bit more expensive
for them to succeed,
to kind of reduce the amount
of traffic they can run."
And then, again, we said
we're taking all of the layers
and we're making business decisions now.
And this is the important part, this is,
you should not let anybody to say,
"Hey, this is what you should do."
It's a business decision
to allow a request
or to deny a request or block a bot
or give them a JavaScript challenge.
And then finally we route them, right?
And so we're a reverse
proxy, we're a load balancer.
So we route the requests, but
we augment them with data.
So GeoIP data, we rewrite the headers,
device information, and
a few things like that.
And some of the standard
routing you're used to
from reverse proxies like
based on SNI, cookies,
path, or anything else in the request,
we uniquely have access to
the entire HTP request, right?
So we can decide how to route,
we can decide to route on an AI model.
If the request is for a specific AI model,
we can route it to a different back-end
based on the data in the request itself.
So again, the idea is
that we're gonna protect
against application layer attacks,
web scrapers, brute forces,
spam on forms and everything else,
targeted exploitation,
scanning, and everything else.
I talked about this actually last year
at a different conference,
but there are obviously
Edge cases to this, right,
at the Edge, as I call it.
So for example, LLMs.
Everybody's doing vibe coding now,
everybody's doing AI.
And the idea of securing AI
is pretty unique and new.
So we are seeing customers
doing new kind of protections
like rate limiting based on
tokens instead of requests
because requests are cheap,
tokens are expensive.
PII detection,
this is very prevalent
in like big enterprises
where they don't wanna send PII to the AI,
they don't wanna output PII, right,
but most likely,
most often they don't wanna
send the PII to the AI.
So they wanna detect that
as quickly as possible
and figure out if there's any
PII and block the request.
And then API key protection,
which is standard API gateway.
So I'm gonna show you an
example implementation of this,
and then actually when I do my demo,
I'll show you everything running.
But this is an implementation
that I did myself.
You don't have to
implement the same thing,
you can if you want, but I did it myself.
So I've decided that we're
gonna do a couple of things,
we're gonna deny, rate limit, challenge,
sandbox, and then allow.
And so, I'm denylisting
bots and IP addresses
that are on a specific list.
I'm denylisting anybody
who's triggering a WAF
over three triggers that's a human.
This is another thing that we've noticed.
Even our largest customers,
very often they say,
"You know what, we're running a WAF.
We don't wanna block
traffic even with the WAF
because that's a big decision."
So they allow one or two
violations to go through
before they start denylisting the traffic.
So if I'm a human, I can
trigger the WAF once, twice,
but three times, then
I'm gonna be denylisted.
So we see that all the time.
Rate limit bots over a specific
anomalous threshold, right?
Like, very often what I do is
allow humans to do 3x the 95th percentile,
allow suspicious clients to do
2x and allow bots 1.5, right?
So humans have the most leeway
in terms of how much rate
they can actually run
versus bots have the
least amount of leeway.
- And in today's day and age,
you kind of have to have
both sides of the coin.
You have to have reputational signals,
which we're providing here as well,
but you also have to behavioral
because with AI and agents nowadays,
it's almost undetectable,
headless browsers and these types things.
So you need a lot of combinations,
and this allows you to
kind of perform that
with all of our tools.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And so, we talked about the whats,
and let's talk a little
bit more about the how.
So this is how we do the configuration
and this is how we show our customers
how to do the configuration.
And we ultimately centralize everything
into the control plane.
And with the control plane,
we centralize all of the policies
so you can then deploy them
across all of your public clouds, VMs,
on-premises, Kubernetes,
and anywhere else.
And the way we do it is
through a unified control plane
where you basically
deploy configuration once
and it's deployed to all
of your HAProxy instances
and you apply security profiles.
So think about like all
of the security you need
to configure on all of the configuration.
When I first made the security
recipe I've shown you before,
it was like 200 lines of configuration.
It was not code, but it was configuration.
We've abstracted away that
specific configuration
to a security profile.
So I can basically on the
left, add all the signals,
those are the detections,
and on the right, I do all
of the decisions, right?
So on the left, I say,
"Hey, is this web scraping?"
On the right, I decide what's
the decision I'm gonna take
to actually react to the web scraping?
And when I do that, I can then
deploy the security profile
to all of my instances.
So again, our customers don't run
one or two instances of load balancers.
They run hundreds across
all of the clouds,
all of their on-premise infrastructure,
all of their regions,
all of their availability zones as well,
because sometimes they try to avoid
cross AZ traffic for many purposes.
So basically I take all of
the steps on the left again
and I decide what are the
decisions on the right to take.
And very quickly, I'm
actually gonna get to this,
and then I can start inspecting
what's gonna happen to the traffic.
So in this case, you can see we...
I think this was a screenshot I took
for the last five minutes.
So in the last five minutes,
we saw 65,000 requests,
we allowed about 46%, so 30,000 of them,
and we took an action on
about half of that as well.
And notice we're calling
it taking an action
'cause we can't say we denied something.
We don't know in advance
what's the action we're gonna take, right?
And in this case, the action, I'm sorry,
in this case, the action was
we're gonna tarpit some
brute force attacks,
we're gonna deny high risk
countries and everything else.
So that's the actual
action that were taken.
So Frank, do you wanna
talk a little bit about
some of the service patterns we've seen?
- And again, all these patterns, again,
they're all possible with HAProxy,
it's just a question of configuration.
So you see the common
ones that that we have are
on the API gateway or circuit
breaker within an API gateway.
And then basically,
you'll see the users will,
they'll be hitting HAProxy
and then you'll have SSL termination,
rate limiting or throttling
as you've seen before,
and different microservices
or circuit breakers of services down,
or if you're consuming too much time.
And then you have other
traffic splitting initiatives
which are kind of like simple
weight-based or other value-based.
So like, typical canary deployments,
or if you're sending 10%
of traffic to version B
but your stable version is version A,
if you're in Kubernetes,
you can roll deployments,
and these types of things.
Blue/green is a similar.
If you have a blue
cluster or green cluster,
HAProxy makes the decision
based on the value
however you pass it to it
and then it switches over to the traffic.
And it's really flexible,
it's really flexible for any pattern.
Again, the whole point of this,
the control plane makes it a lot simpler.
All this configuration is
all possible in the HAProxy.
Control plane gives you
API and client libraries
to be able to simply do this
and make it more seamless
and apply it to different clusters.
And now let's, there's been a lot of talk,
thank you for your patience,
let's see some of this in action.
- Cool, thank you.
So we introduced a couple
of concepts, right?
We introduced the concept
of universal mesh,
we introduced the concept of security.
And so, traffic through the universal mesh
flows through either externally,
that's the north-south traffic,
or internally, that's
the east-west traffic.
And I'm gonna talk about it later.
So imagine that you are an Acme Corp
and you're running a universal
mesh on mesh.acme.com.
And the point is that we're doing
explicit routing of traffic.
So if I'm a service or
if I'm a user out there,
either an external user
or you're mapping to some public domain,
you want to talk to a payment gateway
that's on-premise, right?
You're gonna call
mesh.acme.com/paymentgateway.
And what's gonna happen is
your first HAProxy will ask,
"Hey, where's payment gateway,"
and we'll find out,
"Oh, payment gateway is on this
HAProxy that's on-premise."
So we'll send the traffic there,
and the HAProxy on-premise
receives this traffic
and says, "Where's payment gateway?"
"Oh, that's this spot in this
on-premise Kubernetes cluster,"
and we'll send it there.
Compared to internal traffic,
which actually looks exactly the same.
If I'm a service in a
pod, in US-west-1 in AWS
and I want to talk to the
payment gateway on-premise,
I do the same thing I call
mesh.acme.com/paymentgateway
and the HAProxy that's closest to me
will find out where's payment gateway.
It's on-premise in this
specific data center.
We'll send it there,
and that HAProxy will send
the traffic there again.
So I've made a demo of exactly this.
So if you wanna scan this, I
hope the QR code still works,
if you wanna scan this,
it's the page that I'm gonna show now.
So you should arrive on this page,
mesh.hapee-demo.com/payment-gw, right?
So now, I'm sending traffic externally
from my browser to the
universal mesh and back to,
this is actually a pod
in a Kubernetes cluster.
So if I load this page,
I get an answer and it,
this is because again,
the external HAProxy
decides what's happening,
finds out where to go with the traffic,
and then sends the traffic over.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna,
actually I'm gonna hack myself.
So I'm gonna say path=/etc/password.
There's a path argument,
and if you give it a path of a file,
it will give you the file.
It's kind of fun, right?
So you can do that, but obviously
that's not gonna work
because this is a demo.
So you get 403 Forbidden.
So let's take a look at what happens
in the background, right,
how's this traffic being routed.
So I'm gonna go to the
control plane for HAProxy,
and the first thing I'm gonna
see is there's this request,
payment-gw/ or path=/etc/password.
So that's the one.
And you can see we got a 403 response.
But when I go to the detail,
we actually took an action,
and the action was we blocked this request
because we deemed it
suspicious as a client
and at the same time,
it triggered the web application firewall.
So that was my business decision, right?
I talked about the business decisions.
And my business decision is
if it's a suspicious client,
then do more than to humans.
And you can see the bot management
said that this is a suspicious client
'cause I have some things
in my browser installed
that made me look suspicious.
So as a suspicious client,
we decided to block this
and we triggered an obvious probe
with the path=/etc/password.
That's pretty obvious, right?
So we don't have to talk
about that much more.
The other thing that
we're gonna look at is
instead of looking at the
specific requests that we blocked,
let's actually take a look
at the requests that worked, right?
Some of you actually loaded these,
so some of you will be
these specific URLs.
Obviously, I can't say who's
who in the audience, right?
So somebody requested /payment-gw
and we routed this request to US-east.
That's the HAProxy inside US-east.
And then, we traverse
to the other HAProxy.
And I wanna know what happened to that,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna click on the search here
next to the correlation ID.
So now you see the two requests
as they traverse the network.
And in fact, to the client,
this is a single request, right,
but we see it as two
'cause the first one right
from the client to the HAProxy,
the second was from the
HAProxy to the far end HAProxy
that originates or that's the
destination of this traffic.
And that's this one.
And in here, we're sending the traffic
to this specific payment
gateway service in Kubernetes.
If I make this even bigger,
you can see that, right?
So I'm automatically
detecting all services
inside my Kubernetes clusters,
and here I'm sending the traffic
to this specific Kubernetes cluster.
The last thing I'm gonna demo on this is
we're actually gonna
do some terminal work,
and I'm gonna deploy a new demo.
So here, if you take a
look, if it lets me through,
if you take a look, I
have this new manifest,
and I'm calling this
manifest demoone, right?
And this manifest says that
I'm gonna deploy a new service
and the path of the
service should be /demoone
in the US-east.
And at the top of it,
I have some web server with
just basic information.
So I actually applied it before,
but I'm gonna re-apply it
in my Kubernetes cluster.
So I've created the service,
I've created the deployment.
So if you take a look,
I have some pods of
the deployment demoone.
So that's run in.
I can actually scale the deployment.
I think it was called demoone.
So I'll give it three replicas instead.
But now, if I go to mesh.hapee-demo.com,
I actually get an answer.
And the the point is that the HTML
is the same as the
previous service, right?
But suddenly without me doing anything,
just by deploying a service
in Kubernetes and saying,
"Hey, service path should be /demoone,"
every client in the network
and every HAProxy now
knows how to route demoone.
So if I now go to
mesh.hapee-demo.com/demoone
from externally in this case
and internally at the same time,
I arrive on the pods of
this specific service.
And if I scale the pods,
again, if I change the
number of the replicas, oops,
if I change the number of the replicas,
then this will be automatically updated
and I will be sending traffic
to the five replicas now
instead of the three
replicas that I had before.
So just to recap,
we talked about service discovery
and basically creating
services inside Kubernetes
and automatically
configuring them in HAProxy,
and running multi-layered
security on top of them
where I'm observing in the
control plane what's happening.
And we think that this
is really a solution
to the connectivity problems
that a lot of our customers are having
in terms of talking between
services inside AWS,
but also AWS to GCP and a few other clouds
that they're seeing out there
and they're requesting solutions for that.
And Frank, I don't know
if you wanna close us up.
- Oh, in the end, just, oops...
- Yeah, there you go.
- We just wanna say thank you,
and you can come see us at booth 1179
and you can visit HAProxy
to see some of our
other solutions as well.
But in general, we're happy to discuss.
And just another thing, all
these things are available,
HAProxy is available in
the marketplace in MI.
So it's definitely any form
factor, everything works.
And if you have any questions,
feel free to come and see us.
And thank you for your time.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)